electronic medical records are in a lot
of ways i think the aspect of technology
that is going to revolutionize the way
we deliver care and it's not just that
we will be able to collect information
it's that everyone involved in the
healthcare enterprise will be able to
use that information more effectively
the patient will be able to manage their
own care because they will have the
information about the results of their
tests they'll have information about the
medicines that they're using they'll
have information about the effectiveness
of various kinds of treatments the
physician and the healthcare providers
the nurse practitioners all of the
people that are involved in delivering
care will be able to work more as a
virtual team and use that information to
connect what has gone on in the past in
the pit in their patients lives along
with the care that they are delivering
at the current time and the healthcare
system will be able to use that
information to manage health resources
over the entire population and to
actually improve the quality of care by
focusing on outcomes focusing on the
things that they can do as healthcare
providers to improve the probability of
those positive outcomes occurring
increasingly we know that we're going to
have multiple medical conditions and the
person who's got the greatest incentive
to manage those conditions is the
patient him or herself the personalized
medical record will provide an critical
tool to be able to do that much more
effectively than we've been able to do
it in the past in several cities where
we have investments in the form of
grants we're beginning to see that all
of the major healthcare providers in
that region are using a common platform
for sharing medical and
mation so what that means is that if a
patient goes into the emergency room the
people in the emergency room can
immediately call up onto a screen the
results of the x-ray or the
electrocardiogram or the laboratory
tests that that patient got in the
hospital or in the doctor's office a
week ago what that does is it gives the
ability to manage that person's illness
in real time in a much more effective
way and to do it in a much more
cost-efficient way because you're not
duplicating tests that don't need to be
duplicated and you know the results of
those tests that that will greatly
influence the care that needs to be
delivered at that moment